first of all congratulations i am you  win thank you that was big babe all  right both of us I'm happy though it's a  good testament to the shoulder testament  to our staff that all the work we put in  I'm very happy about that you have quite  a wing great week every week is great  every day is great for me I'm on the  other side of the dirt yeah are you  having fun love it are you looking  forward to GMA in the fall yeah i'm  looking forward to it but i still look  forward to going to work online i love  being there i still love it I think  everybody got this wrong impression of  it but the great show great people and  I'm very fortunate to be a part of it we  surprised how many came such a big news  story that has he now I think the more  I'm talking about anymore becomes a news  story and I don't understand why neither  one of us understand why but it is what  it is